the end of hotel quarantine at least for
the time being yes because there are
seven countries uh currently on the red
list but uh we're expecting confirmation
in the next hour or so that they will be
taken off the list doesn't mean the
system uh is going to be scrapped the
government is insisting uh but for now
these countries peru
ecuador colombia panama the dominique
dominican republic heidi and venezuela
are going to be removed from the list in
another move uh vaccines from at least
a dozen more countries are going to be
recognized we're expecting confirmation
from grant shaps the transport secretary
now um since february this year around
about 200 000 people have had to
endure hotel quarantine for 10 days uh
after coming back from red less
countries uh that a cost of
2285 pounds for adults lower rates for
children anyone who broke those
quarantine rules could see a penalty of
up to a fine of up to ten thousand
pounds i've got some up-to-date figures
here um
last month in september the number of
people uh in quarantine at home was over
400
410 000 and the number of people in
quarantine in a hotel um
in september was uh about four and a
half thousand four thousand four hundred
and sixty six so that makes a total of
uh four hundred and fifteen thousand um
that was mid-september the uh 16th six
six uh
uh 16th to the 22nd then a week a few
the week after that
um the number of people quarantining at
home was roughly the same about 409 000
the number starting quarantine in a
hotel went down slightly uh to um
uh to three hundred three thousand one
hundred and thirty three so not much
difference there so uh
around about um
412 to 414 000 quarantine all together
four thousand four and a half thousand
one week three thousand another week but
those total figures again
since
the quarantine system was launched on
the 15th of february up to the end of
september the number of people starting
quarantine has been a massive uh
those at home over 5 million 5
one
million
25
eleven and the number of people and
quarantining in a hotel with that
massive cost of over two thousand two
hundred pounds uh for adults two hundred
and three thousand three hundred and
sixty so the good news is no more hotel
quarantine for now those countries are
coming off the list but we should stress
if things take a turn for the worst the
red list rules could come back and hotel
quarantine could come back but for today
it is good news uh seven countries
coming off the red list